Hallo Guten Tag, ich bin als Osternsternsarzt auf der Station Stetich. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Annamnese-Gespräch führen. Sind Sie damit ein Interesse?
Ja, Interesse.
Kurz zum Ablauf. Ich werde als Erstes Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Daten stellen, dann direkt zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Maya Müller.
Herr Müller, können Sie Ihre Vorname bestabieren?
Ich bin eine Frau. Ich heiße Maya MA epsilon A.
MA epsilon A.
Genau.
Frau Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 43 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Dann habe ich gleiche Fehler in dem Maat. Moment bitte.
Ich bin 12.5.1979 geboren.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 71 Jahre alt und 1,65 Meter groß.
Was führt Sie zu uns, Frau Müller?
Herr Doktor, seit 2 Tagen habe ich Herzrasen, das ist aber echt schlecht. Manchmal ist mir auch schwindelig.
Vorher hatten Sie Herzrasen oder nur seit 2 Tagen?
Nein, wie kann ich beschreiben? Vor 2 Wochen habe ich auch ähnliche Atakten.
Ich bin einmal umgekippt nach meiner Herzrasen.
Vor 2 Wochen dauerte es etwa 15 Minuten.
Nachdem ich umgekippt war, konnte ich nichts erinnern.
Haben Sie Ihren Bewusstsein verloren?
Kurzfristig, wie gesagt, kann ich nicht richtig beschreiben.
Aber nach kurzem Zeit war ich wieder wach.
Meinen Sie vor 2 Wochen, oder?
Vor 2 Wochen genau. Dieses Mal habe ich nur Herzrasen.
Und wie gesagt, ist mir schwindelig.
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen oder Brustschmerzen?
Eigentlich nicht.
Leiden Sie unter enge Gefühl im Brust?
Nein.
Aber vor 2 Wochen habe ich ähnliche Fragen auch gehört.
Damals wurde bei mir eine Ecke geschrieben. Ich weiß es nicht, warum.
Aber Ihr Kollege hat mir gesagt, dass ich keine kardiale Probleme hätte.
Okay.
wurde eine bestimmte Diagnose gestellt?
Nein. Ich war in der Notaufnahme vorstellig.
Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben keine Ursache gefunden.
Sie könnten nach Hause gehen.
Aber diese Attacke trat wieder auf. Deshalb bin ich da.
Ist Ihnen übel oder müssten Sie sich erbrechen?
Ist mir nicht übel. Aber seit 2 Wochen ist mein Stuhl ein bisschen wesrig.
Wesrig?
Ja.
Schwindel Sie?
Entschuldigung, haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Keine Nachschweiß, kann ich sagen.
Haben Sie Fieber oder Stilfrost?
Stilfrost habe ich nicht. Aber manchmal fühle ich mich sehr warm.
Aber ich habe meine Temperatur nicht gemessen.
Aber wissen Sie, wenn ich warm fühle, bin ich auch ein bisschen kibbelig.
Ich sitze meine Hände. Ich muss immer rausgehen.
Ich kann nicht zu Hause oder in einem Haus bleiben.
Das ist echt schlecht für mich.
Aber damals habe ich meine Temperatur nicht gemessen.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Ihr Stuhl war wesrig.
Haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Beispiel Schaumich oder Terchstuhl?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt. Keine Farbveränderung habe ich gesehen.
Nur ein bisschen wesrig.
Haben Sie Haarausfall bemerkt oder trockene Haare?
Haarausfall, genau.
Das ist seit langem, früher ist es ein bisschen weniger.
Ich dachte, das ist normal, aber in letzter Zeit sehr viel.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihr Haut ein bisschen feucht sein?
Besonders meine Hände.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Erkältung oder solche ähnliche Beschwerden erlitten?
Keine.
Fertigen Sie noch etwas ein?
Haben Sie sonst weitere Beschwerden?
Ja, ich kann sagen, ich habe etwa 5 kg Angewicht abgenommen in den letzten 3 Wochen.
Was ich noch sagen würde, mein Appetit ist eigentlich gut.
Soll ich noch sagen, oder viel für ein Mensch?
Ich esse sehr viel.
Trotzdem habe ich Gewicht abgenommen.
Haben Sie an Ihrem Haar etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Wie zum Beispiel eine Wucherung oder Schulukbesche werden?
Das ist nicht richtig schluckbeschwerden, aber ich fühle mich wie ein Druck beim Schlucken.
Wenn ich gegen ein Spiegel bin, kann ich nichts merken, außer...
Aber diese Druck fühle ich mich, ja.
Okay, Frau Müller, haben Sie Schwierigkeiten ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Durchschlafen, soll ich sagen.
Ich kann einfach einschlafen, aber ich brauche nichts mehr.
Schlafen etwa 3 Stunden danach, mache ich wieder auf, dann ist das genug für mich.
Haben Sie Probleme mit der Wasserlassen?
Bei Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme.
Frau Müller, ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Krankengeschichten stellen.
Haben Sie wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Aktuell habe ich keine Erkrankungen, soll ich sagen.
wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, als ich 18 war, wurde mein Bildarm entfernt.
Ansonsten, nein, ja, nur einmal bin ich operiert worden.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder gelegenlich Medikamente ein?
Manchmal, in letzter Zeit, wie gesagt, ich schlafe sehr, sehr wenig.
Zum Schlafen nehme ich Baldrian ein, ansonsten keine regelmäßige Medikamente.
Okay, Draghi meinen Sie?
Wie bitte?
Baldrian Draghi meinen Sie, oder?
Ja, genau, zum Schlafen, wie gesagt.
Haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ich habe gegen Pflaster Allergien.
Und ich kann einen Medikament einschmerzen, damit ich es richtig vertragen.
Nachdem ich dieses Medikament eingenommen habe, habe ich Magenschmerzen.
Wie heißt das? Normalgen oder so etwas?
Okay, normalgen.
Wie äußert sich die Pflaster Allergie?
Als ich allergisch war, habe ich sehr große Hautschlag bekommen und ein bisschen Fieber.
Und meine Ärztin hat gesagt, dass ich gegen Pflaster Allergie bin.
Muss ich immer äußern, damit ich keine grobe allergische Reaktion bekomme.
Frau Miller, rauchen Sie?
Leider ja.
Seit wann und wie viele Zigaretten pro Tag?
Seit ich 15 war, rauche ich.
Ohne Unterbrechung etwa 20, 25 Zigaretten am Tag.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, gelegentlich.
Frau Miller, nehmen Sie nicht persönlich das frutigemäßige Frage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen oder haben Sie Drogen ausprobiert?
Ich habe bisher keinen Kontakt.
In Ihren, Entschuldigung, gibt es in Ihren Eltern wichtige Erkrankungen?
Ja, bei meiner Mutter ist eine erhöhte Blutdruck bekannt.
Und mein Vater hat eine Blutvergiftung erlitten.
Wir haben nicht verstanden, wie es vorkommen ist,
aber die Erste haben gesagt, irgendwie Lungenentzündung
oder so war es, danach kriegt er Blutvergiftung.
Ja, mein Vater hat keine chronische Erkrankung.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Keine.
Okay, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin leidig.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Keine Kinder.
Wollen Sie allein?
Nein, ich lebe mit meiner Freundin.
Was sind Sie von Beruf, Frau Miller?
In welchem Bereich?
Ich bringe Mathe und Sport bei.
Okay, danke Frau Miller.
Ich habe meine ganz wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie auch mich fragen,
oder fällt Ihnen noch etwas ein,
was Sie hinzufügen möchten?
Aktuell keine.
Ja, ich habe ein paar Fragen,
aber das ist unabhängig von meiner Erkrankung.
Vielleicht später, wenn wir Zeit hätten,
könnte ich diese Frage stellen.
Okay, Frau Miller, Sie können immer fragen.
Ich würde jetzt Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann würde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Dann gegebenenfalls manche bildgebende Untersuchungen,
wie zum Beispiel Ultration, Ultraschall-Untersuchung,
und dann sprechen wir uns wieder,
wie wir weitermachen können.
Wenn Sie keine Fragen mehr haben,
dann würde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Vorher möchte ich, was Sie fragen,
sollte ich hier bleiben?
Oder könnte ich heute nach Hause gehen?
Wie gesagt, wir müssen manche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Diese Untersuchungen dauert ein bisschen.
Nach der Untersuchung entscheiden wir,
ob oder wie lange Sie im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen oder nicht.
Okay, Herr Doktor, ich bin ein Verstammener.
Okay, danke Frau Miller.
Welche Symptome sind Ihnen während des Anfalls aufgefallen?
Entschuldigung, könntest du wiederholen?
Sie haben gesagt,
seit vor zwei Wochen
einmal umkippen, singopiert.
Welche Symptome sind Ihnen während des Anfalls aufgefallen?
Bevor ich umkippt war, hatte ich, wie gesagt,
Herzrasen.
Mir ein bisschen schwindelig.
Ansonsten kann ich nicht andere beschwerden.
Zum Beispiel eine Sunge oder eine unwildtulische Miction?
Ja, genau, nachdem ich aufgewacht war,
hatte ich keinen Wasser lassen.
Und meine Sunge ist auch aktuell,
damals war auch gesund.
Ich habe keine Schädigung bemerkt, keine Blutungen, nichts.
Sie haben gesagt,
vor zwei Wochen,
eine Notfallstation gegangen.
Welche Laboruntersuchung war es?
Wie gesagt, Laboruntersuchung weiß ich nicht.
Die Ärzte hat mir nichts weiter Informationen gegeben,
aber ich erinnere mich,
aktuell haben die EKG geschrieben
und die haben gesagt, mein Herz ist aktuell gesund,
keine unregelmäßige Herzschläge hatte ich.
Aber ich weiß nicht, warum die EKG geschrieben haben.
Und ich möchte auch fragen,
dieses Mal soll ich wieder EKG bekommen?
Jetzt soll ich antworten?
Ja, das wäre super.
Sie sind zuständige Ärzte.
Ja, okay.
Ich dachte, wir haben beendet.
Ja, auf jeden Fall,
wir sollten auch jetzt ein EKG schreiben,
um eine Herzkrankheit auszuschließen.
Aber noch weitere Untersuchungen sind sinnvoll.
Und Sie haben gesagt,
dass ich vielleicht ein Ultraschall bekommen sollte.
Was ist Ultraschall?
Ja.
Und was für Ultraschall möchten Sie durchführen?
Ultraschall ist eine schmerzlose,
strahlendfrei Untersuchung.
Es gibt ein Schallkopf,
der Schallwellen ausschütten
und reflektierten Wellen wieder empfängt.
Und diese werden diese Bilder
auf einem Bildschirm dargestellt.
Dann sehen wir Organen und Strukturen
auf dem Bildschirm.
Bei der Ultraschall-Untersuchung
überprüfen wir, ob es ein Schwellung,
Lämpfknoten,
insbesondere in ihrem Schild trüsen.
Es gibt es eine Hocherung
oder Entzündung,
deswegen sollen wir diese Untersuchung durchführen.
Das verstehe ich jetzt.
Noch zwei Fragen.
Ja, bitte schön.
Schwinder, wie ist das Herzdich?
Ist das Drehen, ein Karussel,
oder schwanken Sie wie auf dem Schiff?
Ich kann mein Schwinder so beschreiben.
Ich bin stabil, wo ich aufstehe.
Aber ich bin stabil,
wo ich aufstehe.
Aber alle Sachen, alle Möbeln,
irgendwie direkt um mich um.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie gekrampft,
während der Umkippung?
Meinen Sie Grippe, Erkältung oder so was?
Gekrampft.
Ah, nie, nie.
Ich habe keine Krämpfe.
Ich konnte nicht erinnern,
aber nachdem ich aufgewacht habe,
habe ich auch keine Schmerzen in der Musik.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Geräusche oder Augen sitzten?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Nur sitzten, wie gesagt, in der Hände.
Hände? Ja.
Einmal für Schwachen,
einmal für zwei Wochen ein Schwindel
und heute Morgen einmal ein Schwindel.
Verstehe richtig?
Genau, vor zwei Wochen habe ich einen Attacker
mit den Kopern, wie sie geäußert haben.
Ich bin umgekippt.
Und jetzt, heute, wieder schwindelig
und wieder heiß rasen.
Was ist das zweite Attacker?
Ich habe heute einen Daumen,
die Schwindel, heute.
Heute etwa fünf, zehn Minuten.
Okay.
Noch andere Fragen?
Mein Kollege?
Keine.
Darf ich vorstellen?
Ja, bitte schön.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich möchte heute eine Patientin vorstellen.
Es geht um eine 43-jährige Patientin,
Maya Müller.
Die Patientin sei 165 cm groß
und 71 kg schwer.
Die Patientin stellte sich bei uns
wegen seit zwei Tagen bestehende
Tachikardi und Vertigo.
Außerdem habe die Patientin
vor zwei Wochen solche Beschwerden erlitten.
Vor zwei Wochen habe die Patientin
sein Bewusstsein verloren und umgekippt.
Damals sei die Patientin beim Arzt gewesen
und ein EKG geschrieben worden sei.
Die Befunde von EKG sei unhafällig.
Außerdem klagte die Patientin über
alle Befunde unhafällig.
Nicht nur EKG, andere Laborwerte.
andere Laborwerte auch unhafällig.
Meine Oberarztin, ich verstehe richtig.
Ja, genau.
Die Patientin hat so geäußert.
In der Notaufnahme wurde keine
feste Diagnose festgestellt,
weil alle Untersuchungen unhafällig sind.
Aber die Patientin hat nur EKG richtig erinnert.
Ansonsten hat sie die Laboruntersuchung nicht gewusst.
Außerdem klagte die Patientin über
Tremor an den Händen, Allopäsi, Feuchterhaut
und Globusgefühl in dem Hals.
In der Vegetativannahmesie klagte die Patientin
über Fieberich und Hitzeintoleranz.
Aber die Patientin hat sein Fieber nicht gemessen.
Die Patientin hat die Hitzeintoleranz erwähnt.
Aber trotzdem hat die Patientin 5g
in der letzten 3 Wochen abgenommen.
Außerdem leidet die Patientin an Insomni
und vermehrte Stulfrequenz.
Die weitere vegetativen Annesen
sei unauffällig.
An Feuererkrankungen,
an bei der Patientin
keine bestimmte Erkrankungen bekannt.
Die Patientin sei mit 18. Lebensjahr
wegen einer Appendiktonie durchgeführt worden.
Die Patientin nehme bei Bedarf
Baldrian-Dragil gegen Insomni ein.
Frau Müller reagiert allergisch auf Pflaster.
Die allergische Reaktion äußere sich
durch Eisanten und Fieber.
Außerdem haben die Patientin
Neurologien und Verträglichkeit,
die so Magenschmerzen führt.
Frau Müller raucht seit
5. Lebensjahr.
Bis 25 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Sie trinken gelegentlich Alkohol,
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Familien an einem Nestig
fanden sich Artellhypertonie
bei der Mutter
und Sepsis auf dem Boden
einer lungen Entzündung beim Vater.
Frau Müller habe keine Geschwister.
Sie sei ledig, habe keine Kinder.
Lebe mit ihren Freunden.
Sie arbeite als Lehrerin,
Mathe und Sportlehrerin.
Nach der erhobenen Anamnese
gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf Hypertriose.
Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen
Panikattack, Drogenentzug,
Hypoglychemia, Insulinoma,
in Betracht.
Zur weiteren Abkühlerung würde ich folgenden
Maßnahmen durchführen.
Als erstes würde ich die Patientin
förperlich untersuchen.
Ich inspitiere die Patientin,
ob sie Feuchterhaut,
Handtremme, hyperreflecht sie aufweist.
Außerdem, ich möchte den Heiß palpieren,
ob es Lymphodenopathie
oder beim Schilddrösen
eine Knoten oder Knoten gibt.
Die Labontar suchen könnte
manche wichtige Hinweisen liefern.
Im Labor sollten Schilddrösenwerte,
Blutbildentzündungparameter,
Blikoswerte überprüft werden.
Außerdem, zum
Ausschluss von Herzkrankheiten,
eine EKG geschrieben werden.
Um die Diagnose so sichern,
könnte Ultraschall
an den Halsbereich
erfolgt werden.
Wenn wir eine
Hyperteroise
feststellen,
sollten wir Therapie mit
Thyrostatika einsetzen.
Wir sind z.B.
Propyltyrocyl,
Metimazol, Carbimazol.
Außerdem könnte auch eine Beta-Bloco
sinnvoll werden.
Welche Schilddrösenhormone möchten Sie unterzogen?
TSH,
Freistee,
Freistee 4.
Bei der Hyperteroise erwarten wir
Primärhyperteroise, erwarten wir
Erniedrige TSH-Werte
und Vermehrte T3, T4-Werte.
Sie ist 43,
könnte es auch Autoimmun sein?
Ja, es könnte sein.
Aber am meisten
Morbus Basetto
verursacht eine Hyperteroise,
aber
Hoshimoto Tiroitis
könnte am Anfang auch Hyperteroise verursachen,
aber danach Hoshimoto Tiroitis
am meisten Hyperteroise verursacht.
Und wissen Sie,
welche Antikörpe bei der Schilddröse
untersuchen wir?
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Ich habe vergesst Antikörpe.
Bei Morbus Basetto
erwarten wir Erhörte
Egal, welche Tiroitis
könnte irgendwelche Antikörpe
im Blut auch ein bisschen erhöht sein?
Tiroperoxidase Antikörpe
Mitochondriallantikörpe vielleicht
auch.
Ja, ich habe auch im Kopf TREK,
aber wenn Sie fragen,
welche Abkürzung ist das,
ich kann auch nicht richtig sagen.
Troglobulin Antikörpe
kann ich auch nicht richtig sagen.
Cirоидperoxidase Antikörpe
und TSA Resector Antikörpe
Ja, das ist TSA Resector Antikörpe, genau TREK
Ist das so?
Ja,
soll ich noch was fragen?
Ich würde etwas sagen.
Wenn Sie möchten,
Fiebrich ist auf Deutsch, dass die Patientin hat Fieber über 38. Die Patientin hat nicht
selbst gemessen, wir haben bisher nicht gemessen, deshalb könnten wir nicht sagen, die Patientin
ist Fiebrich. Wir könnten einfach sagen, die Patientin haben Hitzeintoleranz, Punkt.
Sonst, wir wissen nicht objektiv, wie viel Grad ist das aktuell.
Und Rauchnernamnese zum Beispiel, das ist nur eine Empfehlung. Sie können auch noch gute
Langsätze bilden, aber wenn sie rechnen, sie hat etwa 28 Jahre Rauchnernamnese, aktuell
Raucht und etwa ein Packungsjahr könnten wir sagen, sie ist fortführende Raucherin mit 28
Packers. Wenn man fragt, dann könnten wir einfach sagen, seit dem 15. Lebensjahr, aber das brauchen
wir nicht. Das, wie viele Packers ist für uns wichtig. Und Glucose in Deutsch auch akademisch
nicht verwendet wird, einfach Blutzucker. Das ist alltäglich, aber im Krankenhaus sagt man
auch Blutzucker, kein Glucose. Glucose ist nur als Infusion, was wir geben könnten.
Okay, wie sind Sie bei der Prüfung, wie sollen wir sagen?
Blutzucker. Okay. Es ist halt so.
Okay. Und auch, ja, wie gesagt, Sie könnten einfach sehr gute richtige Gesetze bilden und
auch mit Verbindungen wie außer dem Fernsehen oder sowas. Aber zum Beispiel bei 18.
Lebensjahr wurde sie appenduaktömmiert. Das sind sehr, sehr einfach und damit sie weniger
Fehler machen könnten. Ja, Sie haben recht. Ich habe so notiert, deswegen habe ich so
gesagt, aber ich habe falsch gesagt. Nur ein bisschen zusammenfassen, das ist auch
Zeit. Man kann einfach Zeit gewinnen oder sparen. Ja, Sie haben recht.
Okay. Ja. Vielen Dank. Das ist alles, was ich sagen möchte.
Für die Rückmeldung und für Ihr Zeit. Danke.